Du bist krank?
Dann gib deine Symptome
einfach bei einer App ein.
Eine Maschine wird mit dir darüber reden,
ähnlich wie ein richtiger Arzt.
Nach rund 20 Fragen erstellt die Maschine
eine wahrscheinliche Diagnose.
Hat diese App das Zeug,
die Medizin zu revolutionieren?
Er hat die App mit Namen Ada mitentwickelt.
Ich glaube schon,
dass sich die Rolle des Arztes
in gewisser Weise verändern wird.
Meine Erfahrung aus den letzten acht Jahren,
wo ich mit sehr,
sehr vielen Ärzten gesprochen
und auch zusammengearbeitet habe,
ist, dass die besten Ärzte diejenigen sind,
die sich bewusst sind,
dass sie mit Unterstützung von Technologien
noch mal bessere Ärzte sein können.
Acht Jahre lang entwickelten Ärzte
und Programmierer gemeinsam die App,
werteten Tausende Studien aus.
Was wir hier sehen,
ist quasi das Ergebnis,
was Ada nach einer Symptomanalyse liefert.
Auf der linken Seite finden Sie die Symptome,
die bejaht oder verneint wurden,
auf der rechten Seite die möglichen
Erklärungen, die Ada liefert.
Und die grünen Linien, die weisen darauf hin,
dass ein Symptom bejaht wurde
und wie stark dann dieses Argument
für eine Krankheit spricht.
Und die roten Linien,
dass das Symptom verneint wurde
und wie stark dieses Verneinen eben gegen
bestimmte Krankheiten spricht.
Rund um den Globus wird die App genutzt.
Sie liegt mit ihrer Diagnose meist richtig.
Die Trefferquote liegt ungefähr so hoch
wie bei einem echten Arzt.
Um die Trefferquote weiter zu verbessern,
nutzen die Macher der App
künstliche Intelligenz.
Der selbstlernende Faktor besteht darin,
dass wir aus den Ergebnissen, die Ada liefert,
und das Feedback,
was die User darauf geben,
ob das gestimmt hat, was für ʼne Diagnose
beziehungsweise Erklärung Ada geliefert hat,
daraus kann die künstliche Intelligenz
theoretisch lernen.
Für uns ist halt wichtig,
dass das nicht automatisch passiert,
sondern dass immer Ärzte dazwischen sind,
die das entscheiden,
ob diese Änderung sinnvoll ist oder nicht.
Damit vermeiden wir,
dass einfach User irgendwelche Sachen
erzählen, die gar nicht stimmen.
Und wie schlägt sie sich im Alltag?
Suraj Gurjar im indischen Djaipur
ist einer der sieben Millionen App-Nutzer.
Die Sprache könnte einfacher gehalten sein,
so dass mehr Leute die App verstehen.
Stoffwechselkrankheiten, Diabetes oder
Fettleibigkeit sollten auch erfasst werden,
mit entsprechenden Ernährungshinweisen.
Bei ihrer Analyse warnt die App die Patienten:
Bei möglichen ernsthaften Erkrankungen
sollten sie zum Arzt gehen.
Suraj Gurjar könnte unter
einer Entzündung der Nasenhöhle leiden.
Das diagnostiziert auch der Arzt.
Die meisten Symptome seiner Krankheit
hat die Software korrekt erkannt.
Das ist gut.
Ich denke,
dass die App den Arzt nicht ersetzen wird,
weil die klinische Untersuchung
sehr wichtig ist.
Aber die App ist ein sinnvolles Hilfsmittel.
Die künstliche Intelligenz könnte in Zukunft,
so die Hoffnung der Entwickler,
Krankheiten schon kommen sehen,
bevor die User selbst diese bemerken.
Ich denke, dass auch KI sicherlich ʼnen
Beitrag dazu leisten wird,
dass Leute länger gesünder leben können
und vor allem dass Krankheiten
oft gar nicht erst entstehen.
Gerade da will Ada auch hin.
Dafür muss das System über viele Jahre den
User begleiten und seine Daten sammeln.
Das könnte so manchem
Unbehagen bereiten,
auch wenn die Appmacher
immer wieder betonen:
Die Daten gehören dem User allein
und werden nur anonymisiert ausgewertet.
Höhere Lebenserwartung für weniger
Privatsphäre,
das gehört wohl zur KI-Medizinwelt dazu.